- [Voiceover] Hello, grammarians.
Hello, Rosie.
- [Voiceover] Hi, Paige.
- [Voiceover] So in this
video we're gonna talk
about compound-complex sentences.
- [Voiceover] So we just
covered complex sentences
in the last video which
is where you've got
a simple sentence or
one independent clause
and then that's accompanied
by at least one dependent clause.
So, the compound-complex sentence
is a little bit different.
In this one you have a compound sentence
which is more than one independent clause,
and also at least one dependent clause.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so
it's like there's compound
and there's complex
and this is a combination of both of them.
- [Voiceover] That's right.
- [Voiceover] Right, okay,
so, compound-complex takes
the more than one independent clause
from a compound sentence
and the dependent clause
or more than one from a complex sentence
and puts them together
so you have at least
two independent clauses and
at least one dependent clause.
I say at least 'cause you
could have more than one
or more than two of either of those.
But, it has to be at least that.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] So, Rosie, just to make sure
this all makes sense,
can we get an example
of a compound-complex sentence?
- [Voiceover] After the storm passed,
I went outside and I picked flowers.
- [Voiceover] That's lovely.
- [Voiceover] Isn't that nice?
- [Voiceover] Okay, so I went
outside and I picked flowers
are both independent clauses.
Ignoring after the storm passed,
if we just had I went
outside and I picked flowers,
that's a compound sentence,
that's two independent clauses.
So then we add after the storm passed
which is a dependent clause
and that makes it compound-complex.
We have at least two independent clauses
and at least one dependent clause.
So in this case exactly
two and exactly one.
Rosie, can you tell me
about your friend Alberto
in a compound-complex sentence, please.
- [Voiceover] Sure.
My friend Alberto, well, you'll see.
Though he has a crippling walnut allergy,
Alberto bravely walked
through the walnut grove,
but he made sure to wear long sleeves.
- [Voiceover] That's a good call.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, he's smart.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, smart kid.
So, again, if we just say,
Alberto bravely walked
through the walnut grove,
but he made sure to make long sleeves,
that's a compound sentence.
There's two independent clauses,
Alberto bravely walked through
the walnut grove is one,
and then the second one is
but he made sure to wear long sleeves.
But then, again, we add a
dependent clause at the beginning,
though he has a crippling walnut allergy.
That is what makes it compound-complex,
it has elements of compound,
the two independent clauses
and it has an element of
complex, the dependent clause,
but Rosie, these are
both the minimum number.
These sentences both have
the minimum number of each
independent and dependent clauses.
So, can we see something maybe
that has like more clauses?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, sure.
Well, let's take a look at
this first sentence we have,
I think we can add a
dependent clause to that.
Let's give it a try.
After the storm passed, I went
outside and I picked flowers
because they were beautiful.
- [Voiceover] Okay, I see.
Right, so this is a case
where we see we can have
more than one dependent
clause if we want to, right.
I know I keep saying this,
but two independent clauses
and one dependent clause are the minimum
for a compound-complex sentence.
It can have more, and it still qualifies
as compound-complex.
So that's compound-complex sentences.
They are like compound in that
they have more than
one independent clause,
and they're like complex in that
they also have dependent clauses.
You can learn anything, Paige out.
- [Voiceover] Rosie out.